[Music]
the Wizards of Waverly Place was a huge
hit it had one of the highest viewed
finales in Disney Channel history but
the show isn't all spells and sparkles
it has some really dark secrets you
won't believe which Russo kid was
arrested with a loaded gun stick around
it to the end to find out if this is
your first time here smash that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up david DeLuise private
photos leaked david DeLuise is the
youngest son of comedy legend Dom
DeLuise he's a gifted actor with great
comedic timing his role on Wizards is
one of his best-known he's famous for
playing one of TV's best loved dads
Jerry Russo is a wholesome character
full of dad jokes
that's why fans were shocked when David
was publicly humiliated by a photo
leaked it's not clear who the photos
were meant for but it was definitely
clear they were meant to be private fans
everywhere were furious with whoever was
responsible for the leak david
supporters called the leak mean and came
out in force to support their favorite
wizard dad his fans weren't the only one
to jump to his defense his former
co-star Selena Gomez was quick to say
that she refused to look at the pictures
she said that she felt embarrassed for
David Selena has had her own
embarrassing leaks so she could totally
relate having your privacy invaded like
that is a nightmare it leaves you
feeling vulnerable and violated David
didn't deserve that at all no one
expected such a shocking exposition of
this lovable actor Selena Gomez lost
herself to the show selena has always
spoken out about how grateful she is for
her fans and a career but she's also not
afraid to tell it like it is the fan
favorite pop singer says she felt
violated by her years working for Disney
she describes slowly losing her
innocence the longer she worked in the
business so forth that's your scare
Harper she also described feeling
uncomfortable as a young woman being so
heavily scrutinized Selena says she felt
objectified she felt violated by being
photographed by older men and things
like her be
they suit she said during the last
season of wizards she felt a shift her
career no longer felt like it was about
her art but something else she said she
had to remove people from her life who
didn't support her the star does say she
has a few very close friends and she
keeps her circle small
in addition selena has faced some
challenges she was diagnosed with lupus
and took some time off to get healthy
and it certainly seems she's feeling
more secure in her post Disney days
Daniel Simonis DUI Daniel Simona's won
himself a lot of fans in his role as
Dean Moriarty he was one of Alex's love
interests
Daniel played a bad boy on the show and
it seems like he may be a bad boy in
real life too Daniel recently attended
the Burning Man festival deep in the
Black Rock Desert of Nevada
the festival is known for wild art free
expression and even some bad behavior
Daniel's seemed to embrace the wild side
of Burning Man when he was arrested for
driving under the influence
Daniel was arrested after police saw him
driving very recklessly in a crowded
area that kind of dangerous behavior
takes all the fun out of being a bad boy
it's never cool to endanger yourself or
others Daniel was taken into police
custody
but posted bail the next day hopefully
this was a one-time incident and the
actor will be more careful in the future
he may have been channeling his bad-boy
character but this stunt took it to the
extreme Burning Man is a place to be
wild and free but basic safety and
respect are still relevant the festival
is famous for art cars and bizarre
vehicles police strictly enforced
driving laws and safety precautions the
real waverly place is dangerous waverly
place wasn't just made up for the show
it's a real street in new york city this
city is famous for being a rough urban
place some say the reputation is unfair
but the facts don't lie all major cities
have their fair share of burglaries and
violent crimes waverly is in the desire
neighbourhood of Greenwich Village the
real estate may be popular it should
come as no surprise that the real
waverly place has had its fair share of
tragedies this street has been the scene
of several assaults a man was recently
attacked in front of the Waverly diner
it's hard to imagine the reso siblings
growing up in such a violent place the
family seemed so happy and vibrant it's
kind of strange knowing that their home
is a real place and it's actually a
little dangerous Waverly Place could use
a real life Russo family to protect its
residents it might be able to clean up
the neighborhood a little for everyone's
sake New York City is one of the first
places that springs to mind when you
think of crime filled cities it's right
up there with Chicago it's a little
eye-opening to think of the artsy area
of Greenwich Village as one of the most
dangerous areas in Manhattan Salina and
David dated naturally Selena Gomez and
David Henry aren't siblings in real life
but they did work together almost every
day for four years all of the actors
from Waverly Place have said that after
working together for so long they all
feel like family now the pair vacation
together and were seen dining together
several times rumors flew about the
nature of their relationship some
sources said it was strictly friends but
others confirm the couple Selena and
David are both super cute and would make
a great couple in any other circumstance
having played siblings for so long it's
impossible not to think of them as
brother and sister Selena has even
referred to David as her big brother in
real life that makes the idea of them
dating a little bit weird some claim
that the pair seemed totally platonic
when spotted out in public together
there isn't much evidence of
hand-holding smooching or any other sign
that their time together was romantic we
may never know what those dates really
meant or what they felt for each other
David is now happily married Selena
still spends quite a lot of time with
David and even has dinner at his house
with his family we're not sure what's
more awkward dating your TV brother or
hanging out with your ex's wife we're
just glad that no matter what really
happened David and Selena are still
great friends
scary fan theory any show that has a
massive fan base will inspire theories
Wizards of Waverly Place is a top-rated
show with lots of fans those fans are
creative and have noticed some scary
details according to Psalm eager fans
Wizards of Waverly Place takes
in an alternate Harry Potter universe
where Voldemort wins this theory is a
little outrageous but the science can't
be ignored first off there's the way
some creatures in the Wizarding World
are treated elves are given names at
birth that determine their future jobs
they don't get the right to choose
leprechauns are kept in cages like zoo
animals tutors are never allowed to
visit the families they've worked with
once they leave them all of that sounds
like a world in which the bad guys have
won there's also the one wizard per
family rule and what's with the council
breaking your hands for large breaches
of magic do you remember Fenrir Greyback
the waverly universe has its own
Grayback Mason just like Fenrir he's a
werewolf that's too much of a
coincidence to ignore how is that not
evil the siblings themselves prove how
dark the Waverley universe is alex is
able to use her powers for evil you
can't just go around cloning people
without their permission
she shares a lot of dark qualities with
Tom Riddle too although she does often
come across as a hero
a wizard using the dark arts is the good
guy
that's definitely Voldemort's kind of
world this theory holds up to
examination Dominic it's over you're not
gonna take over the world because I'm
here to save it all the clues are there
the Wizards of Waverly Place is
obviously much darker than anyone
realized Gregg Sulkin betrayed by X lots
of celebrities have been the victim of
embarrassing leaks Gregg Sulkin went
through his own scandal when extremely
private photos of him hit social media
the images were posted by an anonymous
account no one can say for sure who
leaked them but there are some clues
Gregg was known to date bella thorne a
few suspicious details point to Bella
being the source of the lead first
there's the coincidence that Greg isn't
Bella's only ex to suddenly find his
private photos in the public eye another
former boyfriend Tyler Posey was also
embarrassed the same way plenty of
people took to Twitter to point out that
it seems like Bella's exes can't trust
their private photos to stay private
it's definitely fishy that both men had
an ex-girlfriend in common someone who
might have access to these kinds of
images Mela did try to come to Greg's
defense she responded to the leak by
saying it definitely wasn't Greg in the
photos her denial came across as a
little too insistent and lots of people
questioned her motives we may never know
for sure where the images came from but
we do know that something there is
suspicious that kind of a trail from
someone you trusted and cared about is
brutal
Mason is a murderer Wizards of Waverly
Place isn't exactly known as a serious
or dark show fans love the quirky Russo
family and their warmth and if you
aren't paying attention it would be easy
to ignore just how grim the show can be
multiple characters have died grisly
deaths in a disturbing pattern it seems
more than one character has met their
death because of one person Mason no
worries love I'll just stay here and
have a Mason was Alex's lovable werewolf
boyfriend fans love this adorable couple
maybe that's why no one noticed that
Mason is a serial killer it's no secret
that Mason is a jealous boyfriend when
Alex started spending time with her
boyfriend Dean Mason was not there for
it Mason confesses what he's done to
Alex no one seems too excited that
Dean's just been eaten like they don't
even react like a person was just eaten
that's not the only time Mason's
jealousy has led him to homicide in
Wizards return Alex vs. Alex Mason finds
himself at the top of the Leaning Tower
of Pisa joined by Alex her ex-boyfriend
Dominic and most of the Rousseau
extended family he's about to kill again
Mason is thrown into a jealous rage and
charges at Alex's ex Dominic cobbles
over the rail as Alex barely has time to
dodge out of the way that's too gruesome
acts caused by Mason losing control of
his jealousy that's a pretty grim detail
that seems to go overlooked public fight
David Henry is a pretty polished guy
he's a happy family man who loves his
wife and is excited to be a dad he's
definitely a wholesome guy that a lot of
fans look up to even his former co-star
Selena Gomez says she looks up to him as
an older brother even someone as lovely
as David can get upset or make mistakes
David's dark side came out in 2010 when
the actor was recorded
involved in a serious argument he was
fighting with Alex Marshall from the cab
it's not clear from the footage exactly
what started the disagreement the video
clearly shows the Wizards star shouting
with another man several people surround
the pair and appear to be preventing
things from getting physical it looks
like several people including a bouncer
are holding David back he seems to be
ready to attack Alex the crowd
thankfully keeps the two apart and it
never gets worse than a shouting match
this incident was years ago David is
probably much more mature now and looks
back on it as a mistake we may never
know what started the fight but we're
glad it ended too quickly and without
anyone getting hurt it must be pretty
embarrassing for everyone that it was so
public david henrie arrested with a
loaded gun david henrie was a fan
favorite in his role as justin one of
TV's most beloved big brothers seems as
wholesome as apple pie David is now a
married family man he says he's always
known he wanted to be a husband oh sweet
is that apparently David also has a
bad-boy streak in early September
David was arrested of LAX he was stopped
by airport security when it was
discovered that David was carrying a
loaded handgun the gun was found as
David was screened by the TSA he claims
that it was unintentional David also
said the gun belongs to him and it was
purchased legally it's not hard to
believe that David really didn't mean to
carry the weapon through the airport
when he announced to his fans what had
happened on social media he had kind
words B the officials involved he said
it respected the officers who took him
into custody the star posted bail and
was released the authorities didn't see
him as any kind of danger
we're glad the story ends so well and
that David just made a mistake
he has such a squeaky-clean reputation
that hearing of an arrest was a total
shock to fans David made sure to make a
public statement to assure his fans that
it was a simple mistake and no one was
harmed everyone slips up once in a while
here's hoping David will be a little
more careful with what he carries when
he travels well we hope you enjoyed
these dark secrets and Wizards of
Waverly Place see you next time
[Music]